لقد فوجئنا جدًا
بحظرنا أو عدم موافقتنا. أستطيع أن أقول
[موسيقى]
هناك تحقيق برلماني ومن
الصعب جدًا بالنسبة لي أن أدلي بأي
تعليقات، لدينا ثقة كاملة في
الحكومة وفي البرلمان وفي
مجلس الشيوخ الأسترالي.  الحكومة
لذلك سيتعين علينا أن ننتظر ونرى
النتيجة التي سيتوصلون إليها
[موسيقى] لقد
وجدنا أنه من غير العادل للغاية
طلبنا المشروع بعدم الاستجابة
خاصة في الوقت الذي كنا فيه
ندعم أستراليا في
إعادة
المواطنين الذين تقطعت بهم السبل من جميع أنحاء العالم.  العالم من
وإلى أستراليا
يساعدهم في الحصول على الإمدادات الطبية
وقطع الغيار وما إلى ذلك خلال
الفترة المرغوبة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية [
موسيقى]
الوزير الذي لا يكون صادقًا مع
الجمهور الأسترالي
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك